don't let people make their problems
your problems how many times have I said
that
every day all right so all right so
we'll make this one hour bit a bit of a
highlight reel since it's uh Father's
Day and I might even expand on a little
bit further on uh
Monday's unplugged Alpha show
um so
people like to make their problems your
problems don't they oh I can't pay that
uh bill yet because my cat sprained its
eye looking at a disco ball can you take
the mortgage payment out in a week or
something like Believe It or Not people
do this all the time and
I'm using that as a little bit more of
an extreme example because I've done
I've done private mortgages and I've had
people literally tell me oh I can't make
my mortgage payment because I had a
surprise vet bill for my cat or some
show like that and it's like that's your
problem that is a problem that you
encounter it is not my problem do not
make your problems my problem make sure
your payment clears and you know there's
no leniency you know situations like
that you know people like to you know
they're looking for a little heartstring
somewhere on you to pull and some people
say that I'm cold you know and okay you
know maybe I'm a little bit cold maybe a
little bit stiff in that sense but
as a guy I think you have to err in that
direction rather than being soft in a
pushover because people will take
advantage of you right you've probably
seen this in your life right Mom yeah I
would say most of the time that you have
people that bring stuff like that to you
it's almost always a result of failure
to plan on their part it's always an
emergency it's because they failed to
put the right fail safes in place they
fail to do the right things that were
going to prevent that I mean there's
things look yeah obviously there are
things that happen and there's acts of
God and stuff that we can't control but
if you're not constantly thinking about
your situation and making contingency
plans and you're just flying by all
right I've only got this one thing and
I mean there's this sort of Romanticism
around you know throw all caution to the
wind and just quit your job tomorrow and
just go be a drop shipper or something
like that but right there's there's a
lot of guys that offer really good and
solid advice around that that say like
that's the dumbest thing you can do like
there's like a lot of Lamborghini Bros
selling courses that are telling people
to do that
um but yeah so it's it's you know if
you're not constantly kind of evaluating
your situation and saying if XYZ happens
then how am I gonna survive or pay bills
or or what am I going to do what am I
going to lean on and I can sum that up
in one sound bite mop poor planning on
your part does not constitute an
emergency on my part that's another way
to say it basically you're don't make
your problems my problems
um I learned this actually from my
friend's dad in my 20s and you know he
was an entrepreneur he was running a
very successful business at that time
and it you know I overheard him on the
phone talking to somebody and I could
clearly hear the other guy in the phone
trying to push off a payment due date
and he was already in a rear and he was
just he just basically yelled at the guy
he's like look don't make your problems
my problems and slam down the phone
right he's like I got to do
um again that's a that's a terse way to
deal with stuff but if you want to get
things done in the world I'm telling you
guys you're gonna have to be a bit of an
and it's to get
done you have to one of them I I'm into
like I really love Jay Cutler as a
bodybuilder
um and I really got into listening to a
lot of his stuff and there's a sound
bite where he's like look like when I
was training like I haven't lived in a
box I didn't have any outside noise
people would call me and complain with
their problems and hang up on them like
it just if I'm in the middle of
something and I've gotta if I'm chasing
something I don't have time to deal with
everybody else's stuff yeah and a lot of
people they do it under the guise of
empathy it's like oh have a heart man
like oh how could you be so cold and
it's like think of kind of what you're
asking you're you're asking me to
reinforce bad behavior of somebody that
is going to say okay I can just not do
what I'm supposed to do and I will get
bailed out so where's my incentive to
act right 1000 I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out